hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
on the roommates podcast the video is
called
kevin samuels challenges men's beauty
standards if you guys want to look it up
uh before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
as you guys know i'm trying to get to 15
000 subscribers
and this actually is more interesting to
me
because i've been trying to get the
roommates podcast
to like mentor me and loki they've told
me
no but maybe they'll see this who knows
the first things i don't do is i don't
judge why person wants what they want
if women say that okay one of the first
things i don't do is i don't
judge why person wants what they want if
women say they want a man who's
six feet tall six feet okay that's what
you want you just
want and same thing with a man if that's
what you want that's what you want but
let's say the typical
uh attractive woman what is she wanting
well her beauty is currency
she wants a good she wants a good deal
so the basic line i've kind of given
guys
how how much her beauty's worth that's
how much she's looking for on the dollar
sign
so you can understand a uh
i don't use sevens in my system i have
no adjustable six to six
you know eights nines and tens those are
the women that gets you know
i use the old school standard pam grier
but that would be beyonce today
kelly rowland that would be somewhere
around the line of uh
diane carroll and then halle berry 90s
would that would be
beyonce would be an eight
and eight it's hard to find a ten these
days see
those kind of women have men throwing
themselves
men with resources there's always gonna
be more resources
if i had to pick a ten i'd pick margot
robbie beautiful
literally stunning and i asked the guy
why do you want her more than anything
else
and what these guys tend to want is they
want her for
acceptance but here's the thing
i i don't have a problem with hypergamy
understand something
women want you to be able to pay the
bills all of them
one of my most insightful questions i
ask women do you want to have to pay
substantial bills after you're pregnant
and uh after the six months of asking
that question i've had two women say i
don't mind
that means across the board do you want
to have to pay substantial bills
they they tend to want a man who is in
that top 10 percent
hundred thousand dollars to three to two
their top five percent even one percent
and
here's the reality
do you want those problems because as a
man who has dated
beautiful women i will tell you would i
know more than anything else for men who
have those kind of women
if it doesn't work out or they pick the
woman for the wrong reasons
one of the first things they say i just
want somebody that's going to be nice to
me
see i agree you can't
this is what i always talk about like
one of the things i don't
appreciate about kevin samuels is he
makes it very much about like money
and looks right like looks for women
money for men
i'm not saying that's like 100 false
obviously like a lot of people watch him
there's truth into what he says
but like values in my opinion are more
important and like
common interests life goals
like and just someone who's gonna like
that you're compatible with
that i would personally i would say is
more important than
just like straight money and straight
looks also another thing they don't talk
about
guys you don't have to make a lot of
money if you're wise with your money
like let's say a guy gets married at 35
maybe he doesn't have a high salary
but if he's saved 20 to 30 percent of
his income the last decade
he'll be good for a long time it's
human beings always want what they can't
have but it's a question is
why do you want what you want then go
get that thing
um and what we're trying to do is help
level set more guys to realize that look
man
there there is a lane for all of this
and here's the thing
uh put it in the sales analogy
big big fish called wales accounts
that's a one tenth of a percent chance
that you get them
shoot your shot but don't bank on it
cause you'll go broke trying to close
those things
see what we don't want to tell people to
do is
find something to fit you because that
sounds like you're settling and this and
that and i'm like
when did when did work you know when did
it work with somebody to fit you become
such a bad thing
yeah actually i've i very much agree
with what he's saying here
that's a whole video in itself
you can go let's stay there because this
leads me to
what i've realized has gone on going
back to the initial point about not
being able to rank yourself so
you're familiar with the idea what sort
of mating right yes so basically for
people to know sort of mating
is that people want someone who's
similar to them if i'm nigerian i want
nigeria if i'm catholic i'm white
catholic i'm republican i want
republican views you want somebody
similar to
who you are but the problem what occurs
now is especially we'll get to the women
point later so
fellas relax all right but what happens
is when you view yourself
as a top-notch male yes
you didn't feel as though yes mating
what fits me like you said find someone
who fits you
now you feel like what fits me is a
top-notch
women yes and so you say i don't want
any of these
adjustable sixes fives i don't want
anybody
i just want i i want the h nine to ten
because
i as a man emma eight nine
and ten right and so that's one of the
biggest things that i've been seeing
going on is that a lot of people are not
willing to be honest with themselves
to see really what fits you along the
lines of assorted
mating and that's the thing they talk
about how attractiveness
like like even if people are more
attractive they don't have better
marriages
and having good relationships is so
important guys
like it's so important every happy
person
like gary vee he's one of the happiest
people and he absolutely loves
his family like that is so important and
it gets even deeper than that
because we have told everybody that it
everyone can win
so here's the thing if you to get
from time memorial beautiful powerful
men
are around beautiful women okay we
understand that there's a standard but
see here's the thing
if you've been told everybody can win
and you want the outcomes
the eight nine or the ten but you don't
have the high value
resource that the group defines you try
to pay for it in different ways with
um swag
game and this is why i say there's a lot
of rich people that aren't actually rich
like i grew up around very wealthy
people and it's always the people that
you don't expect
to be wealthy like like literally one of
the wealthiest people
that i know like the
his like wife cleans our house just to
get extra money
on the side and like they literally are
so wealthy
and but it's all it's it's all like it's
counterfeit currency because at the end
of the day
cool you may be able to get her but can
you move in these spaces because when
you go
around these other men who this woman
would tend to hang in these circles
and hang around these kind of men do you
fit with the other guys and they're like
oh yeah he's and see that's the thing
most guys realize that so they know
and here's the men are more realistic
than women because we get rejected more
often but it's still out there they
still want it so here's the thing i tell
guys
want what you want but buy what you can
afford
this is actually a lot more
understanding than i thought like it's a
lot more
practical i really i'm telling you i did
not like kevin samuels when i first like
started watching his videos but now he
has some things that i could definitely
see where he's coming from
you